offensively in his timely shots but his
outstanding defense against the Joker
jokic spins count it and won here
there's no one with size or activity on
the weak side A Beautiful Finish By
jokic
[Applause]
Murray
no good drives on hachimura floats it up
and good
[Applause]
top to Brown thought about it
back to Murray shooter fell down Murray
three-pointer puts it in Jamal Murray
part of a 9-0 run he's got 33 that's his
first points of the second half
fans nervous right now here in L.A
Lakers down by 10. under five to play
Joker's beautiful pass lays it up and in
in the fourth quarter of game two in
Denver that's the same shot a cushion
given
he takes it and makes it answers back
with a three-pointer Nicola yokich 14
fourth quarter points
under three minutes remaining going
right back to the two-man game Murray
inside double team spins flips it up and
in
Jamal Murray with a couple of buckets
here in the fourth
off the dribble spins into the paint
kicks it out porter porter tucks it in
Porter knocks it down and that makes it
117 103.